what's the hardest part of being a
cinematographer
the hardest part of being a
is probably
well i reserve the right to take this
back uh and but
i think well in general i think
time is always the enemy so is what is
trying to manage
time i think that's uh
a big part of filmmaking and probably
life
too is just just time you can never make
more time you can make
everything else but you can't make more
time and
as a cinematographer you're always going
to be
torn between ooh
i could add another light or we could
bring in some negative
you can always tweak an image but
the more time you give something now the
less time you'll have
in the evening for the scene that's
later so you're constantly
compromising uh so i it's so it's
either the battle with time or the
battle with ego
i really i'm the more i work the more i
realize
ego really takes up a lot of space on
set
and it's not and i don't mean just other
people's ego
though i do also mean that but really
your own
especially as cinematographer hierarchy
gets very tricky you know
on ice i've always been a feature film
nerd and it's almost easy
on a feature the director's the boss
generally like that's so it's almost
a cleaner thing but the more tv i've
been doing
it's my job to make sure that there are
visual through lines and sometimes you
have a director who comes in
and maybe wants to do something that
isn't in the language of the show
and you try to balance like okay i want
to give the director what they want but
i have to also make sure that the show
runner that we're
or whoever the producer whoever might be
the creative through line
that they're getting what they need and
that i'm also making sure that we're not
getting off track too far
and finding
the places to to curb my own
ego when there are other people telling
me that we need to do something that
feels wrong
or or maybe just i don't like you know
whatever that is and and trying to quiet
my ego so that i can be logical about
something like okay is this
just because i want my idea to be right
or is this
actually affecting the what we're
working on right now like how much
is ego versus you know
something that's actually for the show
and i've been lucky that over the last
four years i've been working on a lot of
series and just really going going going
and it's helped me i think
i think if i had done some of the jobs
i've had in the last year
if i had done them five years ago i
think i would have done
a significantly poorer job
because just because of my own ego
which i hate to say but i it's something
that i've noticed more and more is
keeping my own mind quiet while on set
and learning to listen
as opposed to talk and get all my ideas
out it's really trying to
yeah navigation of ego i guess so
time or ego it's one of those two as the
probably the trickiest part of my job
i think and this is going to go back to
humboldt state again but do you think in
some ways
um it was so supportive that when you
came to another place that was maybe
more competitive
that it was more difficult to navigate
or that's just that's my ego
yeah right no i think it's it's
interesting because
going back to humble and my grad school
this is this is the
one of my arguments for film school
actually is
to to be in a place where you can
fail constantly like like it's okay
it's not only okay you should fail you
should swing for the fences
and fall on your butt like it's i think
that's important
and it it also because my program was
small and you were doing everything it
did
give me confidence for sure so i had you
know
it's easy to be a big fish in a small
pond
but when you move to los angeles like
nobody cares and
i you know i was i was shooting i was
like one of the only people
that anyone would call to shoot a short
up and humble
and then i came to la and it took me
years before i could get anybody to let
me shoot anything for free
i was gripping and then gaffing for a
while and
it definitely uh yeah i mean i guess
that was also
tricky for my ego but again same thing
i worked with with the with a gentleman
hollywood heard
was his name uh i don't even remember
what his real first name was but
we all called him hollywood and he was
an older gaffer
and he taught me a lot he and
a big part of it was keep it taught me
to keep my mouth shut because i
you know i was used to being somebody
who
had opinions that people would listen to
on tiny tiny little
sets and he gave me my first work in los
angeles on
you know low budget features that kind
of thing
and realizing like i'm a small cog
in a very large machine and
watching people make mistakes that i
some of them i could foresee
was very frustrating he'd be like oh the
sun is by the time this track is laid
down
the sun will be behind those trees like
i can see it and they're like no
this isn't your job you could you don't
tell them how to and then
i'd watch that happen so so it was hard
to learn to shut up
but also really good for me
you know that's i like to
when i'm on set i encourage my crew to
give me
ideas i love gathering ideas it doesn't
mean i'll take them
but i'm very open i love collaboration
but i also you know i do my work and so
if something doesn't fit aesthetically
or tonally
it's easy for me to just be like
i don't think we're going to do this in
on cam i think
that that doesn't quite you know
whatever so i i think
just yeah i don't know i guess it's a
dance because in in humboldt
my ego probably got inflated and then it
got beat down
coming to los angeles and and now i
don't
i guess i don't know where i sit with
with my own ego
always working on it meditating every
day and
which is a habit i picked up because of
film
i i was on a series in albania
that was so stressful i almost had a
nervous breakdown like i had a
really tough time and the director
meditated every day at lunch
and out of pure desperation uh
just to try and do anything i started
meditating
and now i never i haven't missed a day
of
a meditation before a day of shooting in
probably four years i've been yeah
and for how long a period of time do you
meditate so i meditate it's
pretty quick i do ten my rhythm now is
when i'm working i wake up i do my
you know morning stuff at home and i get
to set early
and i meditate for 10 or 15 minutes in
my car
and then i get out i have a little
breakfast and
and then start the day so it's 10 10 15
minutes
every morning before i walk onto set but
always parked right near it and what
happens if you're you're
trying to meditate but then there's this
little oh did i bring that oh didn't i
did i
remember oh sh what if there's like this
nagging voice
about what you're supposed to do yeah i
mean
i have i've been meditating for four
years and i've probably i could probably
count on one hand the number of times
where a little voice wasn't
talking to me so it's just part of it
it's part of the process and that's fine
and
you know i can always deal with it after
my 10 15 minutes is up
so whatever it is uh it it definitely
comes in and out but
i'll just deal with it afterwards
usually
usually the 10 minute span doesn't
affect
anything so yeah i just let those
thoughts go as best i can
what would your advice be for let's say
a young person who comes to
a competitive set it doesn't have to
just be la
and what i've seen with competitive
environments is there's a lot of
unwritten rules and you'll never
you you learn trial by fight you know
you're going to find out that oh that
wasn't okay
but you didn't know it so what would
your advice be and they're
they're just someone that has good
intentions they're not trying to
climb up they just think that that's the
way to do it but they're not sure
this is like an un sort of uncharted
territory yeah i mean being on set
is tricky for sure for everyone and if
you're
newer um i think i mean really
i think the biggest piece of advice for
anybody who wants to work really in
any capacity uh on a film set
is be kind and be humble
like it doesn't like if you're if you're
right and you're witnessing people be
wrong
fine like that you don't need to express
that like it's okay
to just swallow some of your comments
and just
be i mean really film work especially
narrative like features tv uh longer
shorts
they're exhausting they're so time i
mean everything
and you know once you get to hour 14
on day 26 everybody's exhausted
everybody's stressed people miss their
families
it's it's a very film work is very
difficult
and the people who you surround yourself
by
or who you are surrounded by affect
everything your mood your ability to
think and if somebody is
challenging you constantly even if
they're right
it it beats you down and you only have
so much energy i think of it sometimes
like a battery
just being drained and if you have to
spend five percent of your battery
dealing with a personality like then
that's removing five percent from
something else
and the people who seem to get hired
more are people who are pleasant to work
with
and i think that's
something that surprised me a lot about
los angeles
but it also it just delights me i never
thought that
you know being kind would help your
career
but it makes perfect sense now that i'm
on set and i realize how exhausting
people are everybody myself included
we're all exhausting
everybody needs something from
you know whether we need affirmations or
whatever it is
we're draining we're exhausting as a
species so
when somebody is easy and still does
their job
it's a magical combination and so i
really i think
everybody's eager especially when you're
young and you're
new you're eager to get ahead or i want
like this or you know or just chasing
money or whatever it is
i think slowing down and just being in
the room
and yeah learning to read a room
that's the other thing so i think being
kind and learning to read a room
when it's tense you know maybe be a
little more quiet
when everybody's in a good mood like
that's great jive along with it but
being reading the room knowing when to
be quiet
which is just most of the time uh
i think that stuff all helps but really
being kind being humble
i think goes it takes you far in life i
think
i'll check back in 20 years
that's great wow i like that story so
the guy
he he was you said a gaffer or he was
like
and he's he was kind of saw you and said
like don't
don't do this and don't do that yeah he
really he he would get in my ear and
he's
sort of you know he's a big personality
so
you know i don't know i don't know i'd
be i'd be curious i haven't seen him in
15 years probably so i'd be curious to
see how he's doing now but
for me i got frustrated
seeing people with way more experience
than me
so i i thought i knew better
and he was just like hey that's not your
job like that's a big part of it is
i had come partially coming from such a
small school
and small town you show up on set you
you're gonna do a little of everything
sound lighting crafty like you you're
gonna get your fingers in every aspect
of it
and being on sets there were still
you know small movies but you have your
lane
and i would offer to help other
departments and if they wanted help
great and if they didn't that's also
great like it
so i think learning your position
and knowing you can't do everything uh
unless you know you are so there are
some directors who
are great at everything there are very
few of them but there are some
who are just very knowledgeable but that
also tends to lead to
micromanagement and people don't tend to
enjoy that you know people want to
feel like collaborators they want to
feel like they have
um some input on on you know have their
fingerprints on a project
in one way or another so yeah
i think i think just learning to not
just do your job and with a smile on
your face if you can manage it
you